Told you about some of the symbolic
associations that that gather around say
images of the unknown.
You could also think of the
unknown has unexplored territory,
but it's a tricky kind of territory
because if the person beside you does
something spectacularly weird,
you move from explored territory to
unexplored territory as soon as you don't
understand what they're doing.
So it's not exactly
spacial temper territory.
It's more like it's more like
temporal spacial territory.
It's time and space because the same
place can be a different place from one
moment to the next.
Not happens all the time when some event
that you don't expect occurs in the
place that you are so and your
body is prepared to react,
it's instinctively prepared to react to
the emergence of chaotic circumstances.
It basically does that by hyper
activating your preparation for action and
increasing your capacity to pay attention
and preparing you to do a very large
number of things at once because
you don't know what to do.
It's a high stress reaction,
but it's built into you.
And it's so interesting because what
that means that is part of what's built
into people is the ability to deal
with what they don't understand.
This is a real paradox,
right?
Because how can you deal with
what you don't understand?
You don't understand it.
So,
but the answer is,
well,
you ramp up your ability to react in a
very large number of ways and you do that
by increasing your general level
of arousal and your attention.
And it's a good,
that also increases the probability
that you're going to be attentive to new
information and pull it in and utilize
it so that you can decide how to act
rapidly.
So other things happen.
For example,
you know,
some of you may have been in car accidents
or events like that where you knew
for a few seconds that the event was
going to occur and time slowed down.
It's quite a common,
uh,
commonly reported phenomena.
I've experienced it a
number of times actually.
And,
uh,
it was actually experimentally tested.
They,
uh,
threw people off Bungee cord apparatuses,
you know,
so apparatuses,
so they were plummeting down,
you know,
in a quite frightening manner.
And had them look at digital timers that
were flashing information while they
were falling.
And it turned out that the people who
are falling could process the digital
information faster than people who
are just standing there under normal
circumstances.
How they got that passed an
ethics committee is beyond me.
But,
but it's a brilliant,
it really is a brilliant experiment.